à
comme péter wright hot fuzz
bonjour à tous cette vidéo la partie en
dessous la commune compte twitter en
coupe d'europe donc une semaine avant le
succès et on trouve le cap d'agde que
nous connaissons
c'est une partie très classique qui
commence par la rega midam il ya comme
un coût est un joueur très solide il est
vraiment difficile d'aller chercher même
propre bilan et cette partie va être un
peu atypique d'ailleurs puisque c'est
vite mais matériel sera déséquilibrée et
il est chaud que va pas manier mais
pièce blanche avec quatre bottés et un
incroyable et puis une efficacité
exemplaire il en 4l des caps cavagnac
6-7 4 6-4 lève 3 des 5 est en tout cas
jouer cavalier c3 ces derniers temps on
a vu beaucoup de catalan c'est à dire 4
g 3 au lieu de les cavaliers c3 ici on
revient à quelque chose de plus
classique fouet set et là il vaut tout
cas choisi cinq faux g5
on peut aussi jouer cinq points f4 ou
alors si les blancs veulent éviter la
simplification qui va survenir dans la
partie commençait par cinq dames c2 et
jouer il faut g5 au coup suivant après
fou g5 iakovenko a répondu h 6 x 4 aux
tirs hoc que 3 et là qu'avait lieu le 4
la simplification dont je parle et donc
les noirs et change de manière
ils ont vertement forcé de pièces
mineurs dès la sortie de l'ouverture et
ainsi ils ont une position peut-être
plus facile à travailler à la maison car
moins compliqué pour prendre celle d'un
premier set c'est prendre des cinq
cavaliers penser trop à dépenser 3 est
maintenant 10e prend des 5
ici on peut voir que les blondes ont
joué c3 c4 dans un avenir proche
qu'ils auront un pion plus au centre
donc une structure de pions un peu
supérieurs mais que d'un autre côté les
noirs n'ont pas de faiblesse et a priori
les bonnes chances de gagner 11 d'amd
trois tours des huit nos c4 dont vous
parlez est ici votre look a répondu
dépensé 4 qui est le coup le plus
fréquent quelques jours après cette
partie à nanjing en chine un an à
essayer le coup surprenant fou aux 6 à
la place de dépenser 4 contre topalov et
il a gagné une victoire assez
impressionnante
maintenant 13 12
vous aussi ce on voit que le pion
bessette est en prise mais sur le temps
d'un premier set
lenoir répondrait des français car tu es
maintenant si les blancs prennent la
tour 1 à 8
dimpre à 8 les noirs répondrait dame b4
et cheikh ould hamma 3 menaçant table
c'est trop à cheikh est un prend 1 et
les positions sont en fait très
dangereuse pour les blancs mais revenons
à dépenser 4 le coup joué par iakovenko
faut penser qu'à travailler à 6900
cavaliers à 5 et cavaliers france
écartent d'où le retrait fouet 2
et maintenant il ya comme un coup il a
choisi le coup tour des six dans l'idée
peut-être de transférer la tour angers 6
pour essayer d'attaquer sur le droit
notre idée est de protéger de manière
prophylactique lecavalier ces six
banques après petit rock foëcy ce qui
est la suite de la partie les blancs ne
puisse pas jouer dame premier set à
cause de tourbe et huit dames assises
forcé et maintenant qu'elle va les
prendre et 4 attendait 6 sata crée alors
la dame assise et baignoire poursuivre
et part car les pointes croire aux
cavaliers prendre donc surtout ici si
votre a préféré 16 dames les deux néo
roman en attaque d'amal attaque du fou
fou des cinq tours fc 1 tour 8
maintenant cavalier 20 donna par yvonne
choc une séance suivant ce que les noirs
ont joué faux f3 ou bien cavaliers
detroit 1 puis cap des 4 cavaliers c5
ici il ya comme un coup s'est décidé
pour le coup tactique cavaliers prend
des quatre qui engendre des
complications en tactique que finalement
ils vont me choque pas mieux maîtrisé
après ça me prendrait quatre l'idée de
les noirs étaient fous pranger 2
maintenant si les blancs essaye de
conserver la pièce de plus en tirant le
thème des 4 et noir jour est fausse et 6
il aurait déjà deux pions pour la pièce
sacrifier et les fortes menaces liées
adam j 5 échecs moutons g6 échec
pour cette raison il est un tube décide
de sacrifier la dame part d'un processus
d'un point dé six cavaliers projet de
après le 21e coude et blanc une position
très déséquilibrée est survenu où les
blancs ont tout refait
et cavaliers contre dame et de pions les
pions noirs en sont assez compacte
tandis que les blancs ont trois îlots de
pions mais d'une manière générale la
position est plutôt favorable aux blancs
ensuite voir avec quelle maestria
il vend de choc va réussir à coordonner
les pièces blanches et quelque chose là
c'est impressionnant donc dans un
premier temps un prêtre des huit tours
ces deux c6 il ya une première phase
d'une dizaine de coups ou i want you va
se contenter de contenir les pieds
adverses et d'améliorer graduellement sa
position on va passer quelques coups
arriver directement 28 28e coup des
blancs trajets 3 ou leur blanc prend
part à la lutte
les pièces blanches ont trouvé chacune
leur meilleur poste temporaire puisque
les pions noirs ne veut pas avancer la
majorité noire sur la dame et contenu
les pions noirs de les droits ne peuvent
pas bouger sans son devenir plus faibles
et donc il faut maintenant essayer de
créer une brèche par la position nord
façon quelques coups pour arriver à 33 1
4 à 5
les blancs fixe les pions noirs les
fixes en plus sur case blanche ce qui
peut être utile puisque le le fond blanc
est un fou de cases blanches donc les
pions ce sont des rats blancs les noirs
sont condamnées à attendre
ayant tchouk va tranquillement amener
ces pièces pour aller inquiéter le
renoir tromper 4,34 sont 17 cavaliers h3
les se dirige vers g5 pour ces sept ans
j'ai deux tons des scènes cavaliers g5
angers 7 points 2 alors ici ils vont
toujours le prend son temps il ne crée
pas de menace directement mais là
c'était probablement histoire de passer
le 40e coup et de prendre les décisions
importantes
quand il aurait de nouveau plus de temps
38 26
m6 qui avait eu quatre ont réussi ce
fleuve 3 pour ce set
voilà le 40e coup est atteint et on
chante joue cavalli g3 menaçant en
passant en fou prend 1,5
il surgit prend elle cinq cavaliers 5
avec une fourche incroyable
ce qui incite la réponse des noirs 41.7
et maintenant il reste à mener les tours
blanches vers les droits pour s'en
prendre au roi noir
on arrive au 51e coup ou les tons blancs
se sont faufilés dans la position noir
ils vont toujours bien de jouer tordre
et des six c'est le premier moment où il
prend un risque puisque calculer quand
même en lâchant le pion à 5
jusqu'ici les blancs contrôler la
position c'est à dire qu' il pouvait
être sûr de ne pas perdre en limitant
les pièces noires et maintenant ils
vendent choc lâche le pion à 5 pourront
utiliser ces quatre pièces et attaquer
les droits inverse d'un point à 5 12
foot des trois tacles pion de six dames
c'est cette frange et 6 dont 17 est ici
si les blancs avaient dû échanger la
tour adverse les noirs on va peut-être
eu des chances tout à fait raisonnable
de tenir avec leurs trois pions passer
des dames
mais il en tout cas très bien calculé et
avec le coup 54 câbles hypron h5 échec
il s'assure la victoire en effet le
pouget si ce n'est pas prenable
car sur 54 a plongé 6 il y aurait trois
points et six échecs et maintenant les
blancs sont gagnants après 55 ou h 7 h 6
échecs congés 8 tours prend 17 dans le
premier set
kiev 6 échecs les moldaves ou bien après
50,5 après cinq tours ainsi ces chèques
qui conduit aux maths
après angie kf3 chez f5 tour h 5 min ils
ont pu convaincre ou a donc dû se
résoudre après que des proches 5 a joué
1 h 6 et après pour prendre cette dame
prend 17 points 6 la cause était
entendue
la partie a duré encore quelques coups
d'un objet quatre échecs qui me léger
trois points g7 temps des six points
fuite
h57 et après 60 ou f5 et comme un coup
abandonné parce que le pion achats les
filets à damas